mais certains à l'instar d'Alexis
Corbière s'insurge de savoir qu'Emmanuel
Macron sera présent lors de cette
cérémonie en compagnie des milliers
d'autres fidèles le président de la
République ne doit pas participer à une
cérémonie religieuse la laïcité c'est la
séparation des Églises et de l'État elle
ne peut être variable selon les cultes
de son côté Emmanuel Macron a tenu à
apporter quelques précisions je n'irai
pas en tant catholique en tant que
président de la République française
alors comment se déroulera cette
cérémonie sécurité coup mais avec Macron
tout savoir sur la visite du pape en
France ce soir dans TPMP
merci à tous
et merci surtout à Aymeric Courbet
d'être avec nous on le suit sur cnews
d'enquête d'esprit il est excellent je
le dis on était très heureux que vous
veniez mes équipes depuis ce matin mais
on espère qu'il Aymeric va dire oui et
merci d'être là c'est un plaisir vous
êtes directeur de France catholique
vous allez nous enduire plus sur cette
visite qui me passionne et je vous dis
j'étais avec des personnes du ministère
de l'Intérieur la semaine dernière et
c'est vrai que c'est la visite la plus
importante et c'est vrai qu'il y a un
dispositif incroyable déjà il arrive
quand le pape il arrive dans une semaine
pile vendredi alors on parle il sera il
sera il aura déjà commencé depuis 3h
alors quand le le pape arrive
qui va l'accueillir en fait c'est alors
d'abord il est accueilli par la première
ministre et d'accord
et puis ensuite ils seront évidemment à
la Bonne Mère à Notre-Dame de la Garde
c'est ça pour une prière parce qu'on
sait que le pape aime beaucoup la Vierge
Marie voilà il va rencontrer un certain
nombre de chefs religieux pour avoir
aussi un moment
de commémoration de tous les migrants
qui sont morts dans la Méditerranée
d'accord et puis ensuite il rencontre
aussi le clergé diocésain donc
c'est-à-dire les prêtres les religieux
et voilà et ensuite il dort à
l'archevêché donc
l'archevêque l'enseignerave qui le
reçoit puisque c'est pas une visite
d'État même si le pape est un chef
d'État le Saint Siège est un état mais
il n'a pas voulu que ce soit d'ailleurs
il l'a dit je viens à Marseille je viens
pas en France ça veut dire que il avait
pas envie d'avoir quelque chose de trop
officiel il voulait quelque chose de
plus informel de pouvoir rencontrer les
gens il va rencontrer aussi des
personnes défavorisées c'est ça et donc
voilà et puis pourquoi il vient en fait
c'est quoi le prétexte d'abord parce que
des rencontres des rencontres
méditerranéennes c'est quoi c'est une
rencontre qui concerne tous les pays de
la Méditerranée donc qui rassemble les
évêques qui sont autour de la mer et qui
partagent un certain nombre de
préoccupations communes d'abord la
Méditerranée c'est là où le berceau de
la civilisation et donc tout autour il y
a des sanctuaires des sanctuaires à la
Vierge marine notamment qui sont
égrainés tout au long de cette mer
Méditerranée et ils vont discuter des
problèmes de leur des problèmes
d'immigration mais pas seulement des
chrétiens persécutés on sait qu'il y en
a beaucoup dans les pays de l'autre côté
de la Méditerranée et il se retrouve
c'est la troisième année et donc il a
été invité par l'archevêque de Marseille
pour venir justement traiter de ses
problèmes et écouter les conclusions ce
sera samedi matin alors il vient avec
qui et bah il vient avec tout un staff
les voyages officiels parce qu'on a vu
le staff de Charles III qui est pas fou
d'ailleurs il a pas un énorme staff
Charles III on l'a vu hier avec Bertrand
Deckers le pape il a un gros staff avec
lui pas énorme il a peut-être une
vingtaine de personnes en fait quand il
vient il vient en avion il y a 70
journalistes qui sont donc dans la
deuxième partie de l'avion et dans la
première partie vous avez une vingtaine
d'officiels qui l'accompagnent sont
chargés de communication c'est proche
collaborateurs etc il va avoir la papa
mobile bien sûr bien sûr mais il paraît
qu'il va prendre aussi une petite Fiat
500 aussi c'est à dire que il va prendre
pas mobile sur l'avenue du Prado et
d'ailleurs les services de sécurité sont
sur les dents parce que c'est le seul
endroit qui sera moins sécurisé ou en
tout cas tout le monde pourra se rendre
là et donc même s'ils ont prévu un
certain nombre de dispositifs c'est vrai
qu'ils ont en tête ils ont en tête ce
qui s'est passé à Nice par exemple au 14
juillet avec une voiture bélier et les
morts qui vont avec donc ils sont sur
les dents donc là le système de sécurité
il est incroyable mais c'est le pape qui
l'a voulu et donc il a passé outre les
recommandations de ces services de
sécurité alors il a quel âge le pape
aujourd'hui 86 86 quel est son état de
santé parce qu'on on dit qu'il est
fatigué déjà vous l'avez vu il se
promène en fauteuil roulant donc là il
va arriver en fauteuil roulant forcément
voilà oui et d'ailleurs une anecdote
mais on va lui offrir un fauteuil
roulant en bois c'est un artisan qui
lui-même a eu un accident et qui s'est
retrouvé en fauteuil qui lui a fabriqué
ça et on va lui offrir pendant son
voyage alors il savait qu'on dit que si
ce voyage est très important
et c'est vrai que il y a beaucoup de
gens voilà qui veulent voir qui veulent
absolument voir le pape parce que c'est
vrai qu'on a comme on dit il est il est
beaucoup de gens disent qu'il est très
fatigué et que c'est vrai que cette
visite en France pour pour nous elle est
très très importante on espère que ça
sera pas la dernière bien sûr on espère
qu'il y en aura beaucoup d'autres mais
c'est vrai que celle-ci est importante
surtout à Marseille vous l'avez dit ça
faisait 500 ans qui avait pas eu de Pape
qui était venu à Marseille alors
Emmanuel Macron c'est le premier
président assister une messe du pape je
crois que c'est c'est pas le premier non
non il y en a eu il y a eu Giscard en 90
jusqu'à en 80 avec Jean-Paul II de
Gaulle évidemment tous les tous les
chefs d'État jusqu'à Giscard
effectivement ont assisté ensuite ça a
été plus aléatoire mais ça reste un chef
d'État qui vient en France donc
forcément Emmanuel Macron sera présent
il va il va comment ça se passe il va
c'est lui qui sait pas lui qui va
l'accueillir mais il va y avoir ils vont
se voir en privé le mal le samedi matin
d'accord et puis effectivement on a
appris cette semaine que il avait
Emmanuel Macron avait confirmé son
souhait d'être présent à la messe en
tant que président de la République il a
dit c'est pas pour communier c'est pas
pour dans une démarche religieuse mais
c'est une démarche officielle d'accueil
et donc il est normal qu'il soit là
justement quand le pape voit le
président de la République il se dit
quoi bah il parle des problèmes de leur
il parle par exemple de la fin de vie un
sujet évidemment qui est en France va
être d'actualité de quoi ils vont parler
ou pas du tout en général c'est préparer
par les services donc ils se disent
voilà vous allez aborder tel tel sujet
avec le pape et le président va va donc
aborder telle ou tel sujet donc avec le
pape qui seront déjà prévu à l'avance
sauf que il peut y avoir aussi de
l'imprévu de l'informel et on sait que
Emmanuel Macron c'est la quatrième fois
quand même qui va rencontrer le pape ça
donc il doit y trouver vous qui savez du
plaisir peut-être ou un intérêt leur
relation
alors on se conseille c'est ce qui se
voit c'est à dire qu'effectivement ça a
été extrêmement chaleureux Emmanuel
Macron a embrassé le pape sur la joue
lorsqu'il y est allé une des dernières
fois il est pas sûr que le pape
d'ailleurs est tellement apprécié mais
enfin ça c'est ça
fait partie du jeu il y a les caméras
donc mais on a l'impression qu'ils
s'apprécie et que voilà il y a peut-être
une relation je sais pas moi filiale
entre les deux 86 ans Emmanuel Macron
moins de 50 ans bon c'est ça peut ça
peut et puis on sait qu'il y a peut-être
une interrogation spirituelle chez le
chef de l'État il a été baptisé à 12 ans
donc il a fait une démarche volontaire
bon il en reste peut-être quelque chose
il va rester combien de temps deux jours
deux jours 24 heures en fait ça même pas
oui parce qu'il vient de 22 il repart le
23 c'est ça oui quand le président de la
République parle au pape en privé ils
peuvent se dire franchement les choses
les points de désaccord par exemple le
pape peut dire je suis pas d'accord avec
votre politique
ça peut ça peut être un peu fight au
bien sûr alors ce qu'on sait aussi c'est
que le pape aime pas trop dans ce genre
de rencontre en secret
voilà il est très à l'aise avec les gens
mais il aime pas rentrer dans le conflit
quand il est en face d'une seule
personne quand il est en face d'un
parterre de personnalité au Portugal par
exemple pas hésiter à dire au Portugal
qui venait de voter l'euthanasie bah
c'est pas bien ce que vous avez fait oui
c'est la seule avec Macron je suis pas
sûr qu'il rentre vraiment dans ces
sujets là alors donc pour refaire un
petit peu le périple du pape il
réalisera donc un entretien avec le
Président de la République il réalisera
ensuite une prière en mémoire des
migrants donc comme vous l'avez dit
disparu en mer à Notre-Dame de la Garde
il défilera ensuite on va la voir avec
sa fameuse papa mobile sur le Prado vous
allez voir la papa mobile voilà donc je
pense que Raymond tu peux faire une
offre
il célébrera une mèche ouverte au public
au sein du célèbre stade Vélodrome près
de 60 000 fidèles sont attendus on dit
selon le diocèse de Marseille le coût de
la cérémonie au Vélodrome s'élèvera à
800.000 euros
juste le Vélodrome c'est ça mais si on
prend tout le reste parce qu'il y a cinq
écrans géants par exemple pour les gens
qui pourront pas aller au Vélodrome 100
000 personnes qui sont attendues donc à
l'extérieur ça veut dire évidemment
beaucoup d'argent mais ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que c'est l'Église en
général qui paye d'accord l'église
locale qui a fait
soyez il va coûter en quoi un million
cinq peut-être exactement un million 5
1,5 millions d'euros la quête de cet
événement devrait rapporter 500000 euros
près de 60000 fidèles ça suffira pas si
c'est un million cinq à combler il y a
un million il y a des mécènes qui vont
être sollicitées
donc c'est ça c'est comment ça se
passait il y a des gens qui peuvent
donner en plus qui peuvent dire voilà
bien sûr il y a un site internet le site
internet du diocèse qui est prévu pour
ça et qui effectivement a déjà fait
appel à la solidarité entre les
différents évêques de France qui vont
tous être présents et donc voilà alors
il y a pas mal de gens qui la décision
d'Emmanuel Macron d'assister à la messe
au Vélodrome ne plaît pas à pas mal de
gens dont Alexis Corbières
le président de la République ne doit
pas participer à une cérémonie
religieuse la laïcité c'est la
séparation des Églises et de l'État elle
ne peut être variable selon les cultes
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à
lexicorbières d'abord je réponds que si
l'État a une certaine neutralité en
revanche la société l'histoire de ce
pays elle est chrétienne il suffit de
voir Marseille la Bonne Mère tout le
monde fait révérence à la bonne mère
quand on est marseillais et qu'on soit
musulman bouddhiste ou athée la Bonne
Mère c'est la protectrice de Marseille à
protéger de la peste etc le protège les
marins en mer et puis il y a des églises
toutes les 100 mètres donc on peut pas
nier que il y a un héritage et que la
société elle est en partie chrétienne
même s'il y a aucune obligation
évidemment de croire mais ne pas
reconnaître simplement ce passé je
trouve que c'est insensé donc vous êtes
il a dit le président que le président
ne participera pas le charisme
c'est-à-dire qu'il ne communiera pas
voilà pour calmer un petit peu les les
esprits mais c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
toute façon dès que vous faites quelque
chose il y a toujours il y a toujours
des des donneurs de leçons des
empêcheurs de
il a déjà fait ça aussi pendant son
quinquennat
exactement
Gérald Darmanin qui est en déplacement à
Marseille ce samedi il en a profité pour
annoncer le dispositif exceptionnel mis
en place pour accueillir le pape Gérard
Darmanin Twitter à Marseille avec les
services de l'État réunion préparatoire
à la visite du pape donc dans la cité
phocéenne les 22 et 23 septembre
prochain cet événement réunira des
centaines de milliers de personnes pour
garantir leur sécurité près de 5000
policiers gendarmes sur mon mobilisés il
sera là Gérald Darmanin il sera à
Marseille
ce qu'on peut rajouter Brigitte le
président bien sûr
il y a 1000 agents de sécurité privée
qui ont été recrutés puisque les 5000
policiers gendarmes 5000 policiers
gendarmes pour les deux jours 1000
agents de sécu privé en plus donc 6000
personnes pour la pour la sécurité les
artères autour du stade Vélodrome seront
bloqués est-ce qu'il y a une crainte
il y a forcément forcément une crainte
et de fait il y a des mesures de
sécurité ils ont passé au pas une fin
tous les bénévoles qui s'occuperont
d'accueillir le pape et certains ont été
écartés parce qu'ils avaient des casiers
judiciaires par exemple les drones sont
interdits enfin c'est effectivement sur
terre aérienne de l'armée de l'air qui a
sur une bulle aérienne au-dessus de
Marseille avec interdiction de survol
des sites ni avions ni drone est-ce que
vous disiez une bulle aérienne on va
rappeler donc c'est vraiment c'est
impossible de survoler Marseille
totalement et tous les services de
l'État sont mobilisés à tel point
d'ailleurs que Monsieur Darmanin
qui va être sur place on dit qu'il va
être instant
priori il a demandé à tous les ministres
d'annuler tous leurs déplacements que
les forces de sécurité se concentrent
sur ce déplacement du pape qui est jugé
évidemment comme névralgique et toutes
les forces de sécurité intérieure
extérieure française sont mobilisés la
dernière visite d'un pas par Marseille
remonte à près de 500 ans c'était en
1533 sans polémiquer malgré tout avec la
gangrène de l'insécurité aujourd'hui à
Marseille on s'aperçoit
il y a une coupe du monde de rugby il y
a une coupe du monde de rugby il y a
beaucoup de choses en France il y a pas
il y a il y a le il y a le roi qui vient
vous dire que là le ministère de
l'intérieur ils sont sur les dents et
ils ont beaucoup ils ont beaucoup
beaucoup de travail bah allez-y vous euh
merci bah vous ferez ben vous vous
pouvez peut-être se rendre à Marseille
mais ministre de l'Intérieur il peut pas
envoyer là c'est c'est total de dire que
5000 policiers peuvent être mobilisés
toute l'année à Marseille toute l'année
déjà
qu'on a du mal déjà qu'on a des
effectifs de police qui sont de moins en
moins importants si on va mettre 5000
policiers à Marseille euh tous les jours
les mecs divers et non c'est pas c'est
pas une question à Marseille mais il
aura plus on aura partout ailleurs donc
c'est c'est quand vous serez ministre de
l'Intérieur tous les deux parce que vous
voudrez Jacques cardeau merci monsieur
je veux une question pour vous est-ce
que vous trouvez pas finalement choquant
vous avez été ravial face à la polémique
notamment de l'extrême gauche que le
Président de la République soit obligé
de dire je n'y vais pas en tant que
chrétien ou catholique moi finalement je
trouve ça choquant qu'il puisse pas
assumer sa foi on en est là aujourd'hui
en France il est chef d'État
il peut pas manifester sa foi finalement
à l'occasion d'une visite
j'aimerais bien avoir votre opinion
là-dessus si tenté qu'il est la foi en
anglais
il a une certaine réserve qu'est-ce que
la laïcité cette c'est une loi de
liberté
qui fait d'abord que le la religion
n'interfère pas dans la politique l'État
est neutre les services publics sont
neutres et nous préservons l'école aussi
et nous l'avons rappelé à cette rentrée
mais la société pour autant n'efface pas
la religion et donc chacun peut croire
ou ne pas croire dans une religion une
philosophie c'est ça la laïcité et en
l'espèce quand nous recevons en France
un chef d'État qui est le pape qui vient
en effet donner une messe au stade
Vélodrome je considère que c'est ma
place d'y aller je n'irai pas en tant
catholique j'irai en tant que président
de la République française qui est en
effet laïque il a dit il va y aller donc
ça y est merci fin du débat ira le pape
François c'est le 266e pape il a été élu
en 2013 c'est vrai c'est vrai qu'il a
été videur de boîte de nuit ou pas
depuis son élection il a effectué 42
voyages à l'étranger et il va se rendre
en Mongolie en septembre et de là il a
86 ans et je vous dis et voyage
actuellement en fauteuil roulant c'est
vrai que c'est un très très gros
événement on espère juste que que ça va
bien se passer oui peut-être une petite
anecdote allez-y pour terminer il se dit
à Marseille que le parcours du pape qui
va être suivi donc par sa papa mobile à
été dévié pour ne pas passer devant la
statue il y a une statue de David du roi
David dans Marseille qui est un homme nu
c'est une copie de celui de Michel-Ange
à Florence et donc pour ne pas que le
pape ne passe devant je sais pas si
c'est vrai mais je trouve que l'anecdote
est assez croustillante oui madame alors
concrètement si on a envie d'y aller
parce que c'est au stade Vélodrome
comment est-ce qu'on fait est-ce que les
places sont payantes ça se passe comment
alors c'est gratuit une messe c'est
forcément gratuit parce que c'est ouvert
à tout le monde il faut aller il faut
simplement s'inscrire là encore pour des
questions de sécurité sur le site du
diocèse de Marseille ok donc c'est les
premiers arrivés les premiers services
est-ce qu'il y a encore des places pour
se priori il en reste encore
quelques-unes mais il faut se dépêcher
première arrivé premier servi comment va
conseiller merci